und wir bleiben beim thema wahl denn der
nächste tagesordnungspunkt im parlament
beschäftigt sich mit der wahl des
bundespräsidenten die fdp fraktion hat
hier einen eintrag antrag eingereicht im
ein gesetzentwurf eingereicht in dem sie
möchte dass der bundespräsident direkt
in allgemeiner unmittelbarer freier
gleicher und geheimer wahl vom volk
gewählt wird momentan ist das ihr so
dass die bundesversammlung den
bundespräsidenten wählt und diese wahl
steht auch demnächst an am 13 februar
und wird der bundespräsident gewählt
erste rednerin zu diesem thema ist
elisabeth kaiser für die spd fraktion
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die fdp schlägt
in ihrem gesetzentwurf vor den
bundespräsidenten direkt vom volk wählen
zu lassen im innenausschuss wurde dieser
gesetzentwurf bereits abgelehnt ich
erläutere im folgenden gern warum unser
grundgesetz die wahl des
bundespräsidenten beziehungsweise der
bundespräsidenten durch die
bundesversammlung
vorsieht und auch das eine gute idee war
der parlamentarische rat zog aus dem
scheitern der weimarer republik die
nötigen lehren und hat sich bei der
erarbeitung unseres grundgesetzes
1948 49 gegen ein präsidiales
regierungssystem entschieden denn damals
hatte paul von hindenburg mit der macht
das vom volk gewählten reichspräsidenten
das demokratische fundament dabei mal
republik durch notverordnungen ausgeholt
und deshalb entschieden sich die
mitglieder des parlamentarischen rates
dafür die kompetenzen des
bundespräsidenten zu begrenzen so ist
der bundespräsident gemäß unserer
verfassung als staatsoberhaupt der
bundesrepublik deutschland format das
höchste verfassungsorgan aber direkte
einflussmöglichkeiten auf die
richtlinien der politik also auf dem
politischen kurs einer regierung die hat
er nicht er ist auch nicht teil der
regierung
dem bundespräsidenten kommen vielmehr
repräsentative aufgaben zu dabei liegt
wichtigste funktion des
staatsoberhauptes sicherlich auch in
seiner integrierende kraft so soll der
bundespräsident moralische maßstäbe
setzen ratschläge geben bei kontroversen
ausgleichend wirken und vor allen dingen
vertrauen vermitteln liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich bin sicher nicht allein
wenn ich anerkennend sagen dass
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
diese aufgabe diese besondere rolle in
dieser aktuell herausfordernden zeit
mehr als gerecht geworden ist
im
direkten austausch mit den bürgerinnen
und bürgern schulter keine kontroversen
zeigt empathie macht immer wieder mut
mut sich auch in schwierigen zeiten für
eine starke demokratie für eine gute
zukunft und seine mitmenschen
einzusetzen und zusammenzustehen ich
freue mich deshalb umso mehr dass frank
walter steinmeier eine so breite
parteiübergreifende unterstützung für
eine zweite amtszeit ab fährt und ich
bin überzeugt das belegen auch die
umfragen dass er auf einer direkten wahl
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger zu hohe
zustimmung erfahren würde aber warum ist
es nun problematisch den
bundespräsidenten direkt zu wählen die
afg führt als grund an dass der wunsch
der bevölkerung besteht dann
mitbestimmung zu haben und nach der die
direkte demokratie
aber wird man diesem wunsch mit der
direktwahl des bundespräsidenten
eigentlich gerecht ich fürchte er dass
unser aktuell fein aufeinander
abgestimmt das verfassungsgefüge mit
entsprechender gewalten und
kompetenzverteilung dadurch ins wanken
kommen würde und dann ein direkt
gewählter bundespräsident
würde dem direkt gewählten parlament mit
dem gleichen machtanspruch
gegenüberstehen den bundespräsidenten
müssten genau so machtvolle
entscheidungskompetenzen zugesprochen
werden mit dem parlament wenn es ja mit
der gleichen hohen legitimation ins amt
gekommen aber welche kompetenzen sollten
das dann sein und spätestens jetzt wird
ja auch deutlich die direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten und die damit
verbundene kompetenz erweiterung die
stunden im klaren widerspruch zu unserem
grundgesetz und darin der definierten
rolle unseres staatsoper das nun
schreibt die afg das ist im falle einer
direktwahl präsidenten dass es keine
weiteren kompetenzen einräumen wolle da
stellt sich mir aber die frage ob das
sich gerade die politikverdrossenheit in
der bevölkerung schüren würde wenn die
bürgerinnen und bürger würden dem
bundespräsidenten zwar direkt wählen
können aber verändern würde das gar
nichts die politische entscheidungsmacht
liebe beim parlament und der regierung
die direktwahl des bundespräsidenten
wurde sozusagen zum selbstzweck und die
bedeutung direkter demokratischer
legitimation durch das volk geschmälert
die wahl des bundespräsidenten durch die
bundesversammlung ist hingegen ein
kluger weg um die angemessene breite
legitimation zukommen zu lassen die
seiner besonderen rolle auch gebührt
wenn die bundesversammlung setzt sich
zusammen aus den mitgliedern des
bundestages und der gleichen anzahl von
wahlleuten die durch die
länderparlamente bestimmt wurden
zusammenfassend lässt sich also
feststellen dass der gesetzentwurf der
afb geeignet ist denn der hat das
stimmenabgabe durch die bevölkerung zu
schmälern und damit frust und
verärgerung bei den menschen zu steigern
der ampel koalition ist es hingegen ein
ehrliches anliegen demokratische
teilhabe zu ermöglichen deshalb wollen
wir auch das modell der bürger räte
evaluieren und ausbauen das ist ein
element und das vertrauen in unseren
demokratischen staat zu stärken
unersetzlich bleibt aber das direkte
gespräch mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
vor ort der austausch der argumente hier
im haus dann vor allen dingen auch das
ringen um die besten lösungen in dieser
herausfordernden zeit zum wohle der
menschen in unserem land und in diesem
sinne freue ich mich auf die weitere
konstruktive zusammenarbeit mit den
demokratischen fraktionen hier im hause
und vielen dank
elisabeth kaiser aus der spd fraktion
hatte die debatte
eröffnen die regierung des
bundespräsidenten kollegen ich weiß dass
sie das teilweise gar nicht so
wahrnehmen aber es ist wirklich recht
laut und auch schwierig dank für die
rednerinnen und redner auch ich bitte
auch wirklich die tribüne darauf zu
achten dass da nicht so viel lernen dann
hier runter kommt als nächster redner in
der debatte erhält philipp amthor das
wort für die cdu csu fraktion wird
anzusprechen staatsorganisation umstadt
modernisierung senders frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
das ja aus der vergangenen wahlperiode
eigentlich gewöhnt dass hier im
wochentakt vorschläge zur änderung des
grundgesetzes aus der fdp-fraktion
kommen und dann könnte man sagen na ja
ein reiner zufall dass wir irgendwann
darüber artikel 54 des grundgesetzes
reden über die bundesversammlung über
die direktwahl des bundespräsidenten
aber eines liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist doch völlig offensichtlich
es ist natürlich kein zufall dass diese
alte diskussion heute fast zwei wochen
vor der nächsten bundesversammlung
aufgewärmt werden soll sondern es ist
völlig offensichtlich worum es in dieser
debatte geht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich bin sicher die afg will
hier im parlament diese debatte über
eine direktwahl des bundespräsidenten
nur
instrumentalisieren um die
bundesversammlung und um unseren
bundespräsidenten zu delegitimieren zu
diskreditieren und ich sage ihnen das
ist kein kluger debattenbeitrag sondern
es ist durchsichtig
und es ist populistisch und ich sage
ihnen insbesondere als cdu-mitglied es
ist auch kein zufall dass sie das sind
dieser woche machen in der sie sich für
diese luftnummer feiern lassen wollen
max otte als bundespräsidenten kandidat
nominiert zu haben den wir völlig zu
recht aus der cdu ausschließen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und ich sage
ihnen in aller deutlichkeit ihren
vorschlag lehnen wir heute ab und auch
wenn es in der sache perlen vor die säue
sind will ich ihn trotzdem noch einmal
einige argumente mit auf den weg geben
kollegin kaiser hat ja schon einiges
gesagt aber es ist natürlich in der
sache so die idee direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten dieses
zugegebenermaßen nicht ganz neu die
wurde in der wissenschaft im parlament
häufiger schon diskutiert in den 70er
jahren im rahmen der verfassungsreform
kommission und spannender weise wenn man
das mal nachliest in den 90er jahren gab
sogar mal einen entsprechenden antrag
von bündnis 90 die grünen von dem hat
die ard auch ganz gut abgeschrieben aber
ich kann ihnen sagen zwei inhaltliche
argumente sind damals genauso falsch wie
heute zum einen sie schreiben in ihrem
antrag die bundesversammlung würde unter
einem demokratiedefizit leiden und ich
kann ihnen sagen das ganze gegenteil ist
richtig wenn man es nämlich bei lichte
betrachtet ist es so dass die
bundesversammlung durch die
zusammensetzung aus uns
bundestagsabgeordneten und zusätzlich
den vertretern der länder sogar das
staatsorgan ist mit der breitesten
legitimation aller staatsorgane da kann
man nicht von einem demokratiedefizit
und hinzu kommt auch man muss schon
sagen kollegin kaiser hat erwähnt
natürlich wäre eine direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten ein erheblicher
eingriff in das kompetenzgefüge des
grundgesetzes und es ist ja geradezu
absurd wie sie argumentieren zu sagen ja
neue befugnisse soll der bundespräsident
dann nicht bekommen man kann doch nicht
ernsthaft vertreten zu sagen wir haben
ein einziges staatsorgan das direkt
unmittelbar gewählt wird und der hat
dann nichts zu sagen das passt nicht
zusammen
ist absurd und es widerspricht auch ganz
klar der verfassungswirklichkeit und
letztlich und das ist das was mich an
ihrer initiative eigentlich am meisten
ärgert ist es ja so sie wollen den
bundespräsidenten doch eigentlich gar
nicht als integrationsfigur sondern sie
wollen eigentlich und das wird auch die
debatte und der beitrag von herrn
brandner zeigen sie wollen hier
spalterische politik auf dem rücken
diese staatsamt ist und das kann nicht
richtig sein wir wollen keinen
spalterischen keinen über politisierten
wahlkampf um dieses amt des
bundespräsidenten sondern wir wollen
dass der bundespräsident ein
integratives staatsamt warnen und wir
sind davon überzeugt die
bundesversammlung ist dafür genau das
richtige gremium sie hat kein
demokratiedefizit und wir lehnen ihren
antrag aus voller überzeugung ab
herzlichen dank
philipp am körper das für die
unionsfraktion für die cdu ist die wahl
des bundespräsidenten besonders heikel
denn die fdp fraktion hat max otte
vorgeschlagen cdu-mitglied und er hat
auch schon gesagt dass er dafür antreten
er wird leon eckert für die grünen
spricht als nächstes
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger die menschen
unserer republik wollen mitgestalten sie
wollen sich einmischen mitdiskutieren
lösungen erarbeiten und diese dann
umsetzen und diese bürgerbeteiligung auf
augenhöhe meinungen einholen
diskutieren einfließen lassen in dem
prozess und dann in der entscheidung
berücksichtigen die habe ich viele jahre
als ratsmitglied bei mir zuhause
praktiziert wenn ich beispielsweise mit
den mitgliedern vom fahrradclub durch
die gemeinde gefahren bin schilder
absperrungen rat führungen neu gemacht
habe dann flossen die gehen dann
sprudelte es dann kam die ganze
kreativität der bürgerschaft hervor und
in meinem wahlkreis in freising
pfaffenhofen schrobenhausen sehe ich
überall dort wo diese bürgerbeteiligung
auf augenhöhe praktiziert wird da
entstehen initiativen aus der
bürgerschaft für die bürgerschaft
getragen von diesen und diese erfahrung
auch die menschen die konstruktiv an
unserem gemeinwesen arbeiten wollen
einzugehen dieser verfehlt den
antragstellerinnen anscheinend
eine wahl ist ein großes versprechen das
versprechen der demokratie an die
bürgerinnen und bürger es lautet deine
stimme zählt und indirekt einfluss
darauf was von wem entschieden wird und
die bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem
land wissen wenn sie personen wählen
landrätinnen und landräte
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeister
diese personen haben danach
gestaltungsmacht können die gemeinde den
ort prägen den landkreis gestalten und
diese versprechen in die wahl kann der
bundespräsident die bundespräsidentin
nicht einhalten ihr fehlt die befugnis
wie beispielsweise in den usa mit
dekreten konkrete politik zu gestalten
es nicht teil der regierung vielmehr
wirkte jahr wirkt unsere
bundespräsidentin unser bundespräsident
durch das wort durch das impuls geben
durch das anstoßen und das kann man
nicht so richtig diskutieren der
vorgelegte antrag schafft also eine
reine zeuge beteiligung an statt echte
beteiligung auf augenhöhe die
enttäuschung ist vorprogrammiert und
politikverdrossenheit wird erzeugt man
könnte fast meinen das wäre der
eigentliche sinn in diesem antrag
und um sich vorzustellen wie denn so ein
wahlkampf aussehen würde muss man ja nur
nach österreich gucken ja und da frage
ich mich ernsthaft wollen wir dann einen
wahlkampf führen um die farbe von
richter rogan um orten oder wir gehen
alle namen durch die ein bundespräsident
vorschlagen wird zum kanzler oder nicht
und wie sehr und wie viele oder wir über
höhen das amt so sehr dass wir alles
diskutieren von rüstungs empor bis zur
op en v vor ort und dann muss der
gewählte am ende sagen ja aber ich kann
da ja gar nicht anpacken haben hier
fehlt ja die befugnis das ist
vorprogrammierte enttäuschung und das
wollen wir nicht nein
[Applaus]
wir nehmen den wunsch nach beteiligung
ernst wir wollen beteiligung ermöglichen
auf augenhöhe und erster verabredungen
sie wurden erwähnt projekte stehen im
koalitionsvertrag bürgerinnen räte deren
vorschläge im parlament dann diskutiert
werden reform des petitionsrecht die den
petenten auch gewicht verleiht sind nur
beispiele mehr muss kommen und für mich
bedeutet das ganz konkret wir müssen
mehr beteiligung mitwirkungsrechte in
die kommunen verankern aber auch mehr
handlungsspielraum und kompetenzen in
die kommunen geben dann kann vor ort
entschieden werden dort wo politik auf
die menschen trifft dann stärken wir
unser fundament das fundament unserer
demokratie und wir stärken auch die
innovationskraft von unten denn dort
sind ganz viele bürgerinnen und bürgern
die sich das beste und die tollsten
lösungen für unser gemeinwesen ausdenken
ich bitte sie liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen diesen antrag abzulehnen vielen
dank
vielen dank herr kollege
das für die grünen als minister spricht
stefan brandt sprecher für wahlprüfung
immunität und geschäftsordnung
derartig die fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
und aus gegebenen anlass hier aus dem
oberhaus sehr geehrter herr max otte
kandidat für das bundespräsidentenamt
einziger nicht irgendwie links verortet
kandidaten bürgerlicher kandidat für das
bundespräsidentenamt für uns der einzig
wählbare kandidat für das
bundespräsidentenamt
obwohl er seit 1991 mitglied der
christlich demokratische union ist dort
die herzlich willkommen und viel erfolg
und viele stimmen vor allem bei der
bundesversammlung am 13 februar meine
herren mehr demokratie wagen das war am
28 oktober 1969 ein zunächst wenig
beachteter spruch von willy brandt mehr
demokratie wagen das gehört aber nicht
nur als spruch zu uns von der afg sei es
ist gelebte dna unserer partei diese
unsere überzeugung mehr demokratie wagen
zieht sich wie ein blauer faden durch
unsere arbeit in den ländern mehr
demokratie wagen das kalb bei uns
beispielsweise bei den forderungen zu
mehr direkter demokratie stichwort
volksentscheide bei unserer forderung
zur amtszeit begrenzung der bund des
bundeskanzlers bei der forderung nach
der abschaffung der parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre stichwort
gewaltenteilung und mehr demokratie
wagen meiner und herren das gehört auch
heute bei unserem gesetzentwurf dazu ab
dem übernächsten male also ab dem jahr
2027 den bundespräsidenten direkt zu
wählen es soll nach unseren
vorstellungen
es soll nach unseren vorstellungen das
möglich werden was in vielen derart dass
sie vielen staaten der erde eine
selbstverständlichkeit ist jeder soll
die möglichkeit bekommen sich als
kandidat aufstellen zu lassen wenn er
0,5 prozent der wahlberechtigten hinter
sich versammelt und die aufgestellten
kandidaten werden dann direkt gewählt
das wäre ein demokratischer strom nach
vorne meine damen und herren gestützt
rund 70 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung wie schön keine kugel ein
mehr in hinterzimmern keine
konsenskandidaten der deutschen
demokratisch die fraktionen die absolute
dominanz der parteien wäre gebrochen
wäre passé einen wahlkampf für die stadt
findet man könnte herausfinden wer steht
wo für das sie sich über unsere fantasie
spielen was das stattfinden könnte wir
haben beispielsweise einen kandidaten
auf der einen seite ein apparatschik
zeit seines lebens irgendwie links von
extrem bis salonfähig verortet aktiv für
eine linke zeitschrift vom
verfassungsschutz
beobachtet zuarbeiter zuträger von
linken funktionären nie irgendeine wahl
gewonnen wer würde solch einen menschen
wären meine damen und herren das ist ja
unsere fantasie weitergehen
stellen wir uns einen gegenkandidaten
vor promoviert an einer
spitzenuniversität in den vereinigten
staaten sagen wir princeton dann
professor an universitäten an
hochschulen in den usa und in österreich
und deutschland sagen wir beispielsweise
boston worms oder graz dann sich nicht
zurückgezogen auf den beamtenstatus den
faktischen beamtenstatus sondern
freiwillige ausstieg aus dem
staatsdienst erfolgreicher unternehmer
autor und redner den von diesen beiden
kandidaten wem würden wo die herzen der
menschen draußen zu fliegen bei einer
modernen für mich stünde die
entscheidung jedenfalls fest so jetzt
haben wir
jetzt haben wir mehrere kandidaten
der ein aussichtsreicher der andere
weniger aussichtsreich das war ähnlich
wie bei der bundeskanzler war auch so
dass völlig aussichtslose kandidatinnen
wie beispielsweise frau berbalk die
jetzt auf dem außenminister jetzt gerade
nicht aber die den außenminister wurde
auch dazu eingeladen wurde ich erwarte
jetzt von den öffentlich-rechtlichen
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass da auch
mal ein trier stattfindet wir haben drei
kandidaten ein von ganz links ein von
mitte-links den konsenskandidaten
bieters wohin sagte der deutschen
demokratischen
fraktionen einen kandidaten den wir als
afd unterstützen der in der cdu verortet
ist in der cdu der erwarten da auch
unterstützung von euch mein auto an um
es möglich zu machen dass jeder bürger
aus dem volk bundespräsident werden kann
bedarf es unseres gesetzentwurf ist
meine damen und herren mehr demokratie
wagen lassen sie uns damit an der spitze
des staates anfangen und machen sie das
was willy brandt heute auch tun würde
stimmen sie unserem antrag bitte zu
vielen dank
stefan brandl war das hat er auch max
otte begrüßt den vorsitzenden der werte
union der cdu bundesvorstand hat am
dienstag berching ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ihn
einzuleiten
wir gehen weiter in der debatte stephan
thome von der fdp-fraktion ist schon am
rednerpult
sehr geehrte frau ihr präsident sind für
die kolleginnen kollegen mehr damen und
herren die rede ist jan brandner hat
doch deutlich gezeigt oder aus der afg
eigentlich ankommt direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten das klingt ja zunächst
mal irgendwie besonders demokratisch und
sympathisch aber nicht alles was auf den
ersten blick plausibel klingt ist auf
den zweiten blick auch noch richtig und
wahr
momentan ist dieses haus der deutsche
bundestag das einzige direkt vom volk
vom souverän gewählt
oberstes organ der bund durch
deutschland und wenn wir nur noch ein
zweites fassungs organ bekommt das
direkt gewählt ist dann ist es natürlich
ein ganz besonders starker auftakt
direkte volkswahl das verleiht eine
besondere legitimation ist ausdruck
eines ganz besonders
vertrauensverhältnisses und diesen
auftrag sozusagen um genuss herumliegen
zu lassen das würde sich mit diesen
auftrag nicht vertragen ein direkt
gewählte bundespräsident tritt neben den
deutschen bundestag und nun ist es doch
die besondere weisheit des grundgesetzes
zu sagen dort wo eine besonders starke
legitimation besteht in form einer
direkten wahl durch das volk da
verteilen wir macht und einfluss auf
viele köpfe auch viele personen und da
wo sich macht und einfluss auf wenige
personen konzentrieren gebündelt sind in
einer person bei bundespräsidenten
bundeskanzler der bundesregierung
obersten gerichtshöfen da wollen wir
dass diese macht nur abgeleitet ist
indirekt und damit gewisse weiß auch
abgeschwächt und das ist eine besondere
weise konstruktion das also
bundeskanzler und bundespräsident nicht
direkt gewählt werden das ist keine
schwächung der demokratie sondern das
verhindert dass direkt legitimierte
einzelne personen die macht in sich
bündeln können an diesem prinzip sollten
wir festhalten und meine damen und
herren
erlauben sie mir ein zweiter gedanken in
ihrem antrag formuliert die afd ihre
sorge um politikverdrossenheit
und um die abwenden oder menschen von
der demokratie aus lfd
da muss ich noch mal zwei wahrheiten
sagen die damen und herren es ist doch
gerade die afd
die keine gelegenheit auslässt und
politikverdrossenheit zu schüren um
parlamentarische fahrt ins lächerliche
zu ziehen um die ablehnung der
demokratie zu schüren zu bevor er
ohne zweiter punkt ist direkt zwar ist
nicht gleich mehr mitbestimmung es ist
zunächst war sogar das gegenteil von
noch mehr macht wird wirt übertragen auf
eine einzelne person
ja wir brauchen intelligente
moderne instrumente der mitgestaltung
durch die menschen im lande aber
direktwahl ist weder besonders modern
noch besonders intelligent ist es mehr
die illusion von mitbestimmung die
entstehen könnte gerade war ein
bundespräsident der ja neben drei
staatsgewalten steht wenn wir nun dieses
amt doch aufladen doch eine besondere
legitimation dann entsteht auch eine
besondere erwartungshaltung aber an ein
amt ohne gesetzgeberische ausübende
unrecht sprechende gewalt von daher ist
die enttäuschung nach gerade schon
vorprogrammiert
und her
und wenn sie mir noch einen dritten und
letzten gedanken erlauben meine damen
und herren ich
meine deutschland hat keinen mangel an
wahlterminen und wahlkämpfen und diesen
wahlkämpfen und weiter wir noch einen
weiteren wahlkampf und wahltermin
hinzuzufügen das stärkt nicht die
demokratie das ist kein mehr an
demokratie ich glaube dass die
bisherigen bundespräsidenten in ihrer
mehrzahl gezeigt haben dass man auch
durch eine indirekte wahl erwartungen
und hoffnungen in diesem amt gut
ausfüllen kann und deswegen spricht in
meinen augen viel mehr gegen eine
direktwahl des bundespräsidenten als für
eine direktwahl ich danke
es soll der bundespräsident direkt vom
volk gewählt werden darüber diskutiert
der bundestag an das ist ein von der
fdp-fraktion eingebrachter gesetzentwurf
der hier in der zweiten und dritten
beratung gesprochen wird nächster redner
in dieser debatte ist nun andré hahn
erst der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
antrag der afg zur direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten geht es mitnichten um
mehr mitbestimmung der bürgerinnen und
bürger ihnen geht es um ein völlig
anderes politisches system die fdp will
weg die afb will weg von der
parlamentarischen demokratie
möglichst hin zu einem totalitär
geführten staat
mit einem möglichst mächtigen führer wir
als linke wollen das nicht
und natürlich
natürlich kann und muss unser
parlamentarisches system verbessert
werden aber ein starker mann an eine
frau denkt die after ja sowieso nicht
also ein starker mann
mit weitestgehend den befugnissen an der
spitze des staates damit haben gerade
wir in deutschland denkbar schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht und die
demokratischen fraktionen hier im
bundestag sind in diesem punkt einig so
etwas darf sich nie wiederholen
das amt des bundespräsidenten ist guten
auch historischen gründen vor allem
repräsentativ der präsident ist durch
die bundesversammlung als gemeinsames
gremium vom bundestag und
länderparlamenten legitimiert und auch
das aufstellungsverfahren ist anders als
von der fdp behauptet nicht
intransparent selbst die rechtsextremen
konnten ja einen kandidaten benennen
auch wenn sie dafür eine anleihe bei der
werte union der union währte union der
cdu aufnehmen mussten frank walter
steinmeier hat seine bereitschaft als
amtsinhaber erklärt für eine weitere
amtszeit zu kandidieren und dafür die
unterstützung verschiedener parteien
erhalten das ist guter brauch in diesem
haus die tätigkeit des bundespräsidenten
nicht öffentlich zu bewerten auch ich
werde das nicht tun möchte ihm aber
durchaus für seine arbeiten in den
letzten jahren danken bei allen
differenzen die es im detail gab und
gibt auch
wir als linke haben natürlich das recht
der bundesversammlung einen alternativen
kandidaten vorzuschlagen und das haben
wir mit gerhard trabert getan der mann
ist wirklich gut und er ist im überholen
ich habe nur an innerhalb weniger und
frage sie ob sie eine frage oder
bemerkung des abgeordneten glaser zu
lassen nein das möchte ich nicht ich
möchte dann müssen sie aber auch gleich
zum schluss kommen dass sehen sie ihn an
das mache ich ich möchte nämlich zu
unseren kandidaten abschließend etwas
sagen er ist ein parteiloser allgemeinen
notfallmediziner und professor für
sozialmedizin erst bekannt als arzt der
arm versorgt obdachlose und nicht
krankenversicherte menschen und er
engagiert sich in der seenotrettung von
geflüchteten vielleicht täte ein solcher
bundespräsident unserem langenhorn auch
mal waren sie mit sitzenden herzlichen
dank
andre hahn stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der linken im
deutschen bundestag hat sich für den
kandidaten der linken hans schabert auch
nochmal geworden und jetzt gibt es eine
kurzintervention von albrecht glaser alt
ich versichere dass ich ganz kurz bin
mit meiner interventionsstelle nur eine
einzige frage an sie können sie sich
vorstellen dass honecker in einer urwahl
gewählt worden wäre
und wer es nicht schön dieses experiment
gemacht zu haben und sich damit viel
totalitarismus erspart zu haben
wünschen sie das wort das ist nicht das
ist nicht der fall dann
dann hat nun der kollege gilt für die
spd das wort
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
als ich nach berlin kam bundestags
bedingt er lernte ich das wunderschöne
wort selbst geilheit kennen brandner sie
sind der phänotyp dafür in ihrer
selbstverliebtheit und ihrem selbst
feiern und ihrem roman auftreten was mit
mehr demokratie nichts zu tun hat aber
was mit mehr selbstverliebtheit wagen
sehr viel zu tun hat
ich bitte sie aber weil die als die ja
auch immer gerne auch meine reden mit
schneidet das jetzt als ein forensisches
lehrvideo zu begreifen und auch zu
nutzen sie haben ja bei der vorstellung
ihres antrages herrn steinmeier
attackiert unter anderem ich zitiere mit
unprofessionalität und hang zum
linksextremismus herr brandner das ist
ungefähr so absurd als wenn man der asd
professionalität und haben zur wahrheit
unterstellen würde
in der hinsicht sind sie aber keinerlei
verdacht zwar beim hand zum
rechtsextremismus sind sie manifester
verdacht zwei
und kombi zur forensik es gibt ja dieses
phänomen dass
brandstifter sich dann als vermeintliche
zeugen melden und nach dem löschzug
rufen so gehen sie mit demokratie und
verfassung das ist eine weise
das andere beispiel manche täter neigen
dazu sie können einfach nicht anders sie
müssen zum tatort des geschehens
zurückkehren jetzt erinnert ein anderer
ein anderes element ihrer vorstellung
ihres gesetzentwurfes dort kritisierten
sie die bundesversammlung als ich
zitiere kurios und willkürlich
zusammengewürfelte truppe und als zitat
nicht diejenigen die das land am laufen
halten eine perfektere
selbstbeschreibung kann man gar nicht
abgeben der täter kehrt zurück zum
tatort
also noch einmal kurze zwischen
zusammenfassung
gesetzentwurf ist handwerklich
professionell
inkonsistent denn sie wollen einen
starken direkt gewählten präsidenten
aber in keine kompetenzen geben das
würde ich heute oder fake demokratie
nennen und wenn sie in diese kompetenzen
geben dann wäre er ist ein absoluter
widerspruch denn damit schwächen sie das
parlament und sorgen letztlich dafür
dass dann der kanzler oder die kanzlerin
jederzeit ausgewechselt werden kann da
aber ein anderer macht pohl ist der
direkt legitimiert ist vom volk und
deshalb so das parlament schwächt das
ist nicht mehr demokratie hatten sondern
weniger dem maler oder bemerkung des
abgeordneten brand selbstverständlich
ich weiß ja dass meine antworten ein
süßer schmerz für ein brandmal sind und
die möchte ich ungern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erstes mal dass wir uns miteinander und
da hatte ich weiß gar nicht wer ihn
verraten hat dass ich auf süßes
schmerzen stehe aber es ist wirklich
sehr gut informiert ich habe nur eine
einzige frage stellen sie tatsächlich in
abrede dass frank walter steinmeier
während seiner studentenzeit und auch
noch danach für eine zeitschrift tätig
war und in einer zeitschrift publiziert
hat sie zur damaligen zeit unter der
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes
standen was also nahe legt dass er frank
walter steinmeier jedenfalls zur
damaligen zeit doch ganz fest im
linksextremistischen spektrum verortet
war
wissen sie das ist irgendwie komisch
wenn man im glashaus so sehr sitzt wie
sie und dann mit steinen wird ist das
wirklich absurd und auf die idee zu
kommen dass frank walter steinmeier
linksextremist da muss man wirklich
schon kreativ sein ich erinnere mich
noch an zeiten in der spd als wir die
gegenteiligen vorwürfe waren da war
vielen er sogar zu konservativ für
sozialdemokratie also das ist wirklich
schon eine meisterleistung
diesem
absolut selbstbewussten
bundespräsidenten der in der mitte
dieser demokratie steht linksextremismus
nachweisen zu wollen und jemand der so
eine karriere des scheiterns in sich
sagt inklusive abwahl als vorsitzender
des rechtsausschusses mit einer fülle
von eindeutig aus meiner sicht rex
rechtsextremistischen äußerungen sollte
selbst fassung treiben und er sich mit
sich selbst befassen und vielleicht mal
ein kloster gehen oder sonstiges
kontemplation würde ihm gut tun
ansonsten wenn wir jetzt von ihren vater
morgana sub sehen und dem wütenden
linksextremismus den sie an und
wahrnehmen wo nichts ist wohl nur
demokratie ist und diskurs und debatte
was in gut hätte was sie aber nicht
haben komm ich
komme ich weiter zur fortsetzung die
angst angst ist jetzt falscher hinweis
wissen sie angst ist ja ihr business
case sie arbeiten mit der angst von
menschen sie interessieren sich doch und
das passt wunderbar zu dem was ich sagen
wollte ist jetzt eine kongeniale
zusammenarbeit die wir haben sie
interessieren sich doch überhaupt nicht
für die demokratie sondern sie
interessieren sich für die demokratie
nur dann wenn sie sie populistisch
nutzen können sie interessieren sich für
frauenrechte genau dann wenn sie damit
fremdenfeindlich stimmung machen können
sie interessieren sich für
antisemitismus genau dann wenn sie diese
antisemitisch nutzen können sie
interessieren sich für körperliche
unversehrtheit genau nur dann wenn sie
damit die wut von bürgern bürger
mobilisieren können und sie
interessieren sich für die
volkssouveränität nur dann wenn sie das
parlament mal ich machen können das ist
ihr verständnis von demokratie und das
nenne ich unlauter und unredlich jeder
der jetzt ihnen zugehört hat muss
begriffen haben dass es ihnen überhaupt
nicht um die verhinderung von
linksextremismus geht und auch nicht um
herrn otte sie benutzten herrn otto und
sie wollen damit die cdu vorführen aber
diese cdu souverän genug sich das nicht
gefallen zu lassen dass der unterschied
zwischen demokraten und nicht
demokratinnen und demokraten und am ende
letzer belegt geht es ihnen auch gar
nicht um steigerung von
bürgerbeteiligung ich habe die
veranstaltung erlebte hartwich als
bundestagsabgeordneter lobte die bürger
räte als es dann aber in die praxis ging
erinnere ich mich an ein call als die
fdp die einzige war die nur lamentierte
nicht genug auf der position alles viel
zu kritisch das ist ein komisches
verständnis wenn sie begreifen
demokratie als das was ihnen hilft und
was ihn kollege lars ist aber ein
parasitäres verstört zu sehen und dass
sie trauen sich unsere
und es ist ein mensch und nicht der
zweck wenn sie saßen heute aus vielen
dank
der letzte redner in dieser debatte
kommt aus der cdu csu fraktion alexander
hoffmann ausgestattet das aus dem grund
die erinnerung an die redezeit gab ich
behandle natürlich jede rednerinnen und
jedem redner entsprechend unserer
geschäftsordnung und mir sind zur seite
er auch zwei schriftführerin und
schriftführer gestellt die darauf achten
und protokoll führen es ist hier guter
brauch wenn das wort zu einer frage oder
bemerkung erteilt wird dass die uhr
angehalten wird und die uhr läuft dann
weiter wenn der fragesteller sich wieder
gesetzt hat und genauso sind wir hier
verfahren in dem moment wo der
abgeordnete brandner wieder seinen platz
einnahmen wie hoch die redezeit hier
entsprechend fort
nun hier noch ein paar erklärende
hinweise von bundestags vizepräsidentin
petra pau zu für die zeit bevor ich das
wort erteilen
frage ich in die runde ob noch ein
mitglied des hauses anwesend ist welches
seine stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat
dann bitte ich das jetzt aber zügig zu
erledigen da die abstimmungs zeit
abgelaufen ist und
ich gebe ihm kollegen alexander hoffmann
für die
cdu/csu-fraktion das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die wahl des
bundespräsidenten steht vor der tür und
das ist natürlich eine gelungene
gelegenheit für die afd
parteipolitische spielchen auf großer
bühne zu betreiben das erleben wir diese
woche das können wir in ihrem antrag
lesen und man spürt es auch bei den
redebeiträgen da oben von der empore man
kann den schönen spiegel vorhalten die
bundesversammlung wird bewusst ohne
debatte durchgeführt weil man vermeiden
will dass das amt des präsidenten das
wichtige amt des bundespräsidenten
beschädigt wird in dem die person
verächtlich gemacht wird mit
wortbeiträgen nichts anderes haben wir
heute von ihnen erwartet und erlebt
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
reihe nach vor ihnen steht tatsächlich
ein mitglied der unionsfraktion dass es
zutiefst bedauert dass wir zur
bundesversammlung keinen eigenen
kandidaten vorschlagen
meine persönliche auffassung ist dass
wir in diesen herausfordernden zeiten
einen präsidenten brauchen der etwas zu
sagen hat und das meine ich inhaltlich
und der nicht immer klingt wie ein
politiker und ich will ehrlich sein in
meinen augen gelingt das dem amtsinhaber
nicht immer und ich will auch einräumen
dass es in meiner fraktion viele gibt
die so denken anders als sie
führt das bei uns aber nicht dazu dass
wir das für parteipolitische spielchen
benutzen dazu ist uns das amt zu wichtig
und die zeiten sind zu schwierig
und auch auf die gefahr hin dass ich
jetzt vielleicht anwesende in die welt
der realität zurückholen muss man doch
mal ehrlicherweise sagen wenn man sich
die debatte anschaut wie sie sie führen
wie sie die vor ihren kandidaten
vorgeschlagen haben wie sie im antrag
erklären dass sie ein besseres verfahren
haben dann muss man doch ehrlicherweise
sagen ihnen geht es doch gar nicht darum
am schluss den qualifiziertesten
kandidaten zu platzieren ihm geht es
nicht darum dass wir am schluss gehen
mit den besten fähigkeiten haben die
gesellschaft zu einem ihnen geht es
nicht darum jemanden zu platzieren der
breiteste gesellschaftliche reputation
hat sondern ihm geht es bei allem was
sie machen egal ob wir über das
verfahren reden oder ob wir über den
kandidaten reden geht es ihnen nur um
drei fragen womit erzeugen sie die
meisten schlagzeilen womit erzeugen sie
die tiefste spaltung und womit können
sie maximal austeilen
sie haben dem grunde nach bis heute
nicht verstanden wie wichtig das amt des
bundespräsidenten ist oder sie wollen es
vielleicht nicht verstehen
nachvollziehbar bei einer partei deren
mittel einzig und allein die spaltung
ist und jetzt hat ihn ja der kollege an
tor freund gelegenheit gegeben im
verfassungsrecht noch ein bisschen
nachzuarbeiten und haben sie mitbekommen
dass die bundesversammlung
per se schon einmal organ sui generis
ist und dass dieses organ heute schon so
ist dass es in maximaler art und weise
repräsentativ die gesamte breite unserer
gesellschaft darstellt und dass das
funktioniert
das zeigt ein blick in die vergangenheit
ich will mal erinnern an ganz
hervorragende besetzung dieses amtes mit
richard von weizsäcker roman herzog
horst köhler oder joachim gauck das
heißt wir brauchen kein neues verfahren
wir brauchen ihren antrag nicht und
deswegen lehnen wir ihn
selbstverständlich haben
so wird also die debatte ob des
deutschen staatsoberhaupt gewählt
werden soll direkt gewählt werden soll
vom volk am 13 februar findet die wahl
des bundespräsidenten statt phoenix wird
natürlich auch diese in gänze übertragen
ab 10 uhr werden wir live sein und ich
kann hier nur sagen aus der redaktion
dass wir dort noch ordentlich am planen
sind es wird viele interviews gegeben
live natürlich und auch wieder eine
kommentierung von vor ort vom geschieden
zur änderung des grundgesetzes
gesetz zur einführung der direktwahl des
bundespräsidenten der ausschuss für
inneres und heimat empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 410
den gesetzentwurf der fraktion der afg
auf drucksache
198 abzulehnen ich bitte diejenigen die
dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um
das handzeichen
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich niemand der
gesetzentwurf ist in zweiter beratung
mit den stimmen der koalitionsfraktionen
der cdu csu fraktion und der fraktion
die linke gegen die stimmen der fdp
fraktion abgelehnt damit entfällt nach
unserer geschäftsordnung eine weitere
beratung also diese gesetzentwurf wurde
abgelehnt